hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
as you've probably already heard by
today Apple decided they wanted to come
out with their own iPhone 6s battery
case they've made their own case before
but this is their entry into the battery
case market so it comes in two colors
there's a black version and a white
version this is what it looks like
it's an 1877 milliamp hour battery so
that'll give you roughly one full charge
and it's supposed to give you Apple says
18 hours of browsing internet on LTE and
20 hours of web video playback so you
slide your iPhone into it just by moving
the top of it backwards like this and
sliding onto that iPhone connector
peeling over the top done this is
probably the only iPhone battery case
that actually plugs in by a lightning
mostly one plug in via micro USB so
that's an advantage to being a
first-party Apple accessory another
thing is in your iPhones notification
tray it'll show you how much battery
life you have left on both the iPhone
and the case it's talking to the iPhone
so that is it that's basically the whole
thing pretty basic honestly if you ask
me super simple look to it not a whole
lot of extra features and everyone's
hating on it right
why first of all the design you've
probably already seen this big bulge I'm
not sure what to call it kind of looks
like there's another ipod underneath the
skin or something there's been other
cases that look similar to this but most
of them look better maybe Apple file you
could kind of like rest your finger on
this Ridge or something here is supposed
to be easier to hold in the hand I don't
know if I'd buy that but that's the way
it looks but the main reason that I and
many other people have been not so happy
about this case is the price it's $100
it's a $99 case right and that only
matters because this is what else you
can get for 99 bucks this is another
case this is by Mophie Mophie is
probably the most popular case maker at
least in terms of battery cases for the
iphone right now so this is their Mophie
Juice Pack err Mophie Juice Pack err is
number one I'd say designed a lot better
it's this nice smooth looking normal
looking case on the back you get it on
to the iPhone by taking off the top
something that Mophie has a patent for
clicks into place
slides the top on number two it's a much
larger battery on the back here like I
said
this is a 1877 milliamp hour battery
this is a two thousand seven hundred
fifty million power battery and besides
just the numbers Mophie has been doing
battery cases for a while so there's a
couple things that people who buy
battery cases will see that mobis
thought about for a while that are just
done better here than they are an apples
first try for the same price so on the
Mophie the battery charge indicator is
on the back you push a button it lights
up it tells you how much charge you have
left on apples you have to turn on your
phone for that and the charging
indicator LED is on the inside of the
case with the Mophie there's an on/off
switch on the back of the case so if you
don't have low battery you can wear the
case on your phone all day but then when
you actually get low you can flip that
switch and then start charging on the
Apple case you have no choice about when
you start charging whenever you plug the
case in you start charging your phone
and movies not the only one doing that
here's another case this is from
lifeproof it's supposed to waterproof
but it also has the battery indicator on
the back and it's also a 2600 milliamp
hour battery you can also get something
like this which is just an external
battery and you've probably seen stuff
like this before but with these you can
get of course much much more power
10,000 15,000 20,000 milliamp hours for
charging your phone multiple times over
it's not quite as portable and sleek
because it doesn't have to be on your
phone but that's another solution for
the same thing so at the end of the day
the conclusion is pretty simple about
this guy this is Apple's first battery
case and it's not the best battery case
you can get for your iPhone obviously
especially because it's 99 bucks you can
get much better for the same price or
even less of links all the things I've
talked about in the description bottom
line now you know it's available to you
thanks for watching
I'll talk to you as the next one peace
you